in 1982 Marvel issued an open invitation
to aspiring artists and writers for a
chance to contribute to the Marvel
Universe
one such contestant was Randy Schuler
from Norwich Illinois who came up with
the idea of a costume upgrade for
spider-man
a costume that will be composed of the
same unstable molecule materials that
made up the Fantastic Four costumes
Marvel would ultimately buy out the idea
and after several edits and revisions
would eventually form into arguably one
of spider-man's greatest villains and
one of the most popular villains of all
time in the Marvel Universe what's going
on guys this is Rob and today we're
going to be talking about venom
so before we get too far into this
discussion there's a couple things we
need to outline and the first is that
whenever we're referring to the Symbian
in this video we're going to be
referring to it as the Venom symbiote
and the reason for this is because in
future videos we'll be discussing the
character carnage and despite the fact
that carnage and the Venom symbiote are
related there are two distinctly
different entities and so in order to
avoid confusion we're simply going to
call it the Venom symbiote in addition
as far as the Venom symbiote house we're
only going to be talking about
spider-man and Eddie Brock since those
are two of the most iconic hosts that
the Venom symbiote has ever taken on so
when it comes to the Venom symbiote it's
actually part of a race of symbiote and
the way these symbionts exist they go
from one host to another in Dallas hosts
with superhuman abilities and at the
same time drain the host to a fatal
point of all the adrenaline and the
reason why this is done is because it's
really the only way that the symbiotes
can exist when the symbiote gives its
hosts superhuman powers the host is very
reluctant to cast off the Venom symbiote
it really kind of becomes a drug kind of
becomes a crutch and so it's a very
parasitic relationship something is
given but the cost is more than the host
is willing to bear if the host is
informed upfront of what's actually
going to be going to happen as a result
of merging with this symbian now with
regards to spider-man coming into
contact with the Venom symbiote it was
actually an accident
the symbiote because of the fact that it
had this drive to move away from going
from one host to another and to bond
with a host permanently it was cast out
by the remaining symbionts of his own
race due to the viewpoint that it was it
was insane and it was in prison on the
newly created battle world during the
secret Wars
timeline which we won't go too much we
won't go too far into as suffice it to
say that the secret war storyline was
actually a battle between some of the
most popular villains and superheroes
which they were forced into at the hands
of the Beyonder the spider-man had
become weakened during this fight he
actually ends up coming into contact
with the Venom symbiote and initially
his spider sense goes off and waring him
a warning him of some sort of danger but
immediately goes away a spider-man suit
you know I would say that within a
reasonable amount of time
spider-man begins to notice different
enhancements that come as a result of
merging with the Venom symbiote of
course a couple of the most notable ones
are the fact that the Venom symbiote
allows him to effectively shape-shift
not to the degree that he can appear to
be other people but to the degree that
he can appear to be wearing physical
clothing and this is a very big asset
for spider-man because it cuts down on
the fact that he on the amount of time
it takes for him to you know take off
his regular clothes and then put on a
spider-man mask and then go running into
battle or to save someone else instead
he can just transform into his a
spider-man suit and or I guess transform
into the to the Venom symbiote itself
and run and fight crime or do whatever
it is that he needs to do the other
thing is that he grants him this very
very durable form of wedding a form of
webbing and this is a much larger asset
because when it comes to spider-man's
webbing it's an artificial level suffice
it to say there was one point in the
Marvel Comics storyline where Spiderman
developed organic webbing but that was
taken away and he was back to making
cartridges but because of the fact that
he has to make Harsha jizz the danger
exists and it actually has happened on
several occasions where spider-man will
run out of webbing and webbing is
probably his greatest asset in terms of
his offensive weaponry against different
villains with the venom simian he didn't
have to worry about that the webbing was
more durable and it was unlimited he
would never run out of it but there were
a couple catches spider-man as time
progressed begin to notice a few things
and one of the things that he noticed
was that he was exhausted and lethargic
almost all the time and the reason why
this was happening was because Spiderman
was actually when he was going to sleep
at night he was not sleeping the entire
time that he was unconscious there were
points during the night when the Venom
symbiote would be controlling his
physical body and he would be going
around and committing various acts at
the same time spider-man also noticed
that the assembiy would move on its own
and in one of the most iconic scenes
from the venom and spider-man series was
the nightmare that spider-man had which
was a battle between the spider-man
costume and
the venom costume and I can't remember
off the top of my head of the venom
costume came out on top but suffice it
to say this kind of set off a few red
flags and so spider-man went to visit
mr. fantastic of the Fantastic Four and
Johnny Storm of the Fantastic Four and
with the three of them analyzing the
Venom symbiote they came to a few
conclusions one was that the Venom
symbiote was of course its own entity
who had its own thoughts its own
feelings and it really kind of did
things of its own accord and this is
where spider-man realized that the
reason for his lethargy and exhaustion
was because a symbiote was controlling
him while he was unconscious the other
thing that they learned was that the
symbiote had a fear of fire and a
weakness to sonic vibrations or extreme
sounds and so they actually ended up
discarding the symbiote getting an
office spider-man and imprisoning it in
the Baxter building
now the symbiote escapes and it travels
back to spider-man's home word disguises
itself as a spare blue and red
spider-man costume and tries to bond
with spider-man again now eventually
spider-man casts off the Venom symbiote
for you know for the final time in what
is probably the most iconic scene in the
venom and spider-man fight where he's in
a church and the bells are ringing and
he's casting off the symbiote it's
actually one of the one of the coolest
parts of the spider-man and venom
storyline and it's one that virtually
every Marvel Comics fan is aware of even
if they're not the most avid spider-man
readers that there are now once the
Venom symbiote leaves spider-man it
really is kind of left with this
embittered hatred of spider-man and
because of this the Venom symbiote
really kind of seeks out and bonds with
individuals who have the same kind of
hatred the first host that it bonds with
and probably the most popular after
spider-man is Eddie Brock because of the
fact that Eddie Brock had been disgraced
as a fraud in terms of news reporting by
spider-man
he had this inherent hatred for
spider-man as well and when both the
Venom symbiote and Eddie Brock merged
into a single entity it really kind of
empowered both of them and gave them
abilities that didn't just belong to
spider-man but were also a little more
extensive than spider-man's but the most
obviously the the big
asset that the Venom symbiote has is
that it is immune to spider-man's
spider-sense and the reason why this is
so important is because spider-man uses
his spidey sense in virtually every
fight that he's in it's really kind of
the upper edge that he has on almost all
the villains that he faces but when he's
fighting fighting venom this doesn't
exist there is no spidey sense venom
could be standing right next to
spider-man disguise and spider-man would
never know so whenever whenever the two
of them are fighting it's always an
extremely dangerous and an extremely
deadly fight and there had been multiple
instances there have been several that I
can think of in the spider-man
storylines where venom and spider-man
have fought and if venom has come out on
time on top despite the fact that he's
never successfully killed spider-man so
with that being said I'm going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end
I hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later peace